[Music]
hey everybody it's monday yep this is
the uh pilot episode
of our discussions and reviews and
investigations of cases that came off
the haunting yeah classic hauntings i
think what we're gonna do like i said is
just do one every week we'll do a
haunting mondays
uh i should have probably made like a
new little uh intro but i mean i could
just
yeah i'll just get around to i didn't
really think about it until today that's
how we do [ __ ] around here
we just gotta like do everything at the
last minute
fancy [ __ ] yeah but i mean we just like
thought of this idea the other day it's
like oh let's start doing like a
haunting episode a week like uh on one
of the matinees because so many people
like ask us about doing those and we
haven't when we still have so many yeah
and if the show if the show gets a good
response maybe we'll add a day or we'll
uh you know if it gets a bad response
we'll drop it we'll come up with
something else yeah but i think this
would be a good idea yeah i'm just
saying we've had so many people like
yeah i've had so many people like
message me and like want to do like get
back to doing some haunting episodes
yeah and then you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of people saying hey you
know you've been on true crime and this
and that what happened to paranormal you
know so
this is a way of [ __ ] killing two
birds at once though yeah hopefully
we'll kind of like
yeah
fill in some of that gap right
so yeah so i had bought tom a long time
ago we had like the um you know the the
box set of the first four seasons we
have some of the other seasons too i
think you can watch a bunch of them for
a free online pluto i think i have a
total of six or six to eight seasons
yeah we should check pluto as well even
though like honestly we kind of like the
the early ones like the first like six
seasons or so i think are the best ones
like after that i haven't seen any
recent ones but i kind of feel like
after season five or six they started
going a little too ludicrous well i
thought you started to hurt for cases
yeah so i kind of feel like yeah and the
company changed hands the franchise
changed hands and they were just hurting
for more and more cases yeah so they
would take cases that were a little kind
of
iffy although you know in the series a
lot of the cases are kind of samey
but that's okay because that kind of
fits
that kind of fits with actual reports
there is a pattern
to them
and you know i've seen paranormal stuff
poultry guys classic poultry guys rspk
if you if you knew the show
wrote a book about it and everything
jenny wrote the book uh based on me and
my family and everything that we went
through which is different
it's not like a haunting similar but
more movement of objects
but we'll get around to that eventually
one day too i actually uh the haunting
wanted to
actually put a case on
put my case on there but lois and red
were [ __ ] going through a hard time
and they didn't want they didn't want to
be on tv
so yeah we talked to the producers like
for uh
back and forth like for a while but we
tried to like convince lois and write it
down i was like come on let's do it but
they didn't want to be on tv you know
you know people in our family and
they're like everyone will laugh at us
and then [ __ ] and then then red died
i mean they could have been on but like
they could have been on in shadow i
guess like if they were really because
we because we watched one last night
where the guy was like in shadow and
didn't want his real name on there some
of the people do that well they also
wanted to film and lois is in red his
apartment they didn't want anybody in
their apartment because and i didn't
know why but that apartment was jab
packed full of [ __ ] musical
instruments yeah
because red
had a guitar electric guitar collection
that was like famous people's guitars
like he had a couple of stevie ray
vaughn guitars
uh i don't think he had a jimi hendrix
but these things were worth [ __ ] tens
of thousands
tens of thousands i think he even had a
randy rhodes [ __ ] guitar
and
he wheeled and dealed from him he got
into the [ __ ] exotic guitar trade i
don't know what happened all those i
guess wesley got him
i don't even know if they're worth money
anymore i don't know if people collect
people uh guitars from rock stars yeah
of course they do do they okay people
collect all kinds of things like the 70s
or 80s that she was big deal but uh yeah
he has a so place was filled with
[ __ ]
he was a music teacher and the place was
just filled with the ceilings full of
[ __ ] guitar cases
so probably look like a hoarder's house
in there
danny rowling said the lakeshore club
episode yeah i remember that one in
season one of a haunting was a decent i
definitely i definitely do want to do
that one because that was one that i
remembered like from uh back when we
were watching it all the time
we started watching um
we had a disc that had three episodes on
it and the first one that we watched
last night the one that we were gonna
cover and we'll probably get around to
it at some point is called the attic
but then like we just went ahead and
watched the next one and the next one i
was kind of like oh i think i like this
case better uh so let's do this one
first because this was kind of one and
as it turned out it was a little bit
easier to find
uh external sources about this case
because the woman at the center of this
case actually wrote a book about it as
well
so i didn't have a chance to read the
whole book but i read like portions of
it and i read like some reviews of it
where people like talked about what's
going on in there so we can kind of talk
about the episode and then i can because
uh the episode left a lot out
you know which i guess it always kind of
does but it's weird because the stuff
that they left out i don't know why they
would have left it out because some of
it actually would have been pretty
exciting but i don't i don't know it's
just weird i don't know how they
determine they're in there talking about
who the best episodes are and that they
have hugo said he's got the at least he
said uh what the first uh season
he got that on on cd
on uh well no he's talking about that
movie the haunted oh the haunted
remember we reviewed that one a little
while back that was about that that true
haunting yeah yeah yeah yeah remember
that so this one was made for tv right
yeah yeah it was a pretty good it was
actually a pretty good movie it was
pretty good for made for tv yeah
so the one that we're going to be
talking about today is season four
episode one which is called
dark wrath yeah and if you don't
remember this one this is the one where
the husband [ __ ] cuts it bashes his
way through the door what did he have an
axe yeah it was doing the old here
here's johnny jack torrance yep yeah
doing a little bit of the jack torrance
thing i don't think he got locked up but
they did get divorced afterwards well
they weren't married they were no okay
they weren't they were just like
longtime boyfriend girlfriend situation
the actor that plays uh that guy's uh he
comes off as being just [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh um shifty as [ __ ] too
well i think i was really like um from
what i read about it like i said i don't
i don't know what his last name was but
um from what i read about him he was
much shiftier than they actually
portrayed him on the show because i kind
of feel like on the episode i think they
were trying to make it seem like the
house was having more of an effect on
him than it did like oh they were normal
like before they moved into that house
which wasn't
exactly true okay but um we'll kind of
get into that yeah in the episode the
guy that's playing him i think he's
actually a good actor because he comes
off being being a real slime ball yeah
he does yeah yeah i think he was in some
other episode well because like a
haunting if you watch like any number of
episodes they have like a stable of
actors that they use over and over again
yeah the regulars they're yeah regulars
are great because sometimes they go over
the [ __ ] board and you can tell
they're just getting ready to bust up
but you know what i mean you get to know
the regulars watching the watching the
seasons it's funny yeah so yeah you get
to recognize it i was like hey it's it's
what's her name from you know where evil
dwells or whatever it's just like it's
really the woman that always plays
lorraine warren the smell of sanctity
yeah it's like yeah it's exactly some
[ __ ] that [ __ ] lorraine warren would
say she probably she was spraying
[ __ ] roses rose petals spray and [ __ ]
yeah smell this
yeah
because that's what i'd be doing yes the
spirits are gone oracle says uh waves
like crazy to everybody and tells them
that they try the thai peanut curry in
tom and jenny's cookbook is amazing oh
thank you yeah yeah that's right yeah
because she was telling me she made it
and i was like oh my god i love that
speck peter curry so much it's like so
so good yeah what country are you in
who's this oracle it's original okay
yeah yeah yeah she's american
uh murder hornet says the same producers
that did a haunting made my favorite
series locked up abroad ooh i also like
yeah i also like that series
a lot getting locked up and been [ __ ]
you're in another country bad [ __ ]
happened to you that's a really good if
you like if you like the haunting go
check out lockdown yeah locked up abroad
that's like pretty and it's like pretty
much every single person it's like well
i was just trying to like you know just
smuggle a few uh grams of cocaine up my
butt and then like i'm going into like
turkey or somewhere and like they got
caught yeah and then i'm like well
yeah or people getting locked up by
terrorists and stuff yeah that happens
too but i mean i feel like 85 90 of it
it's like it's drug smothered like
little bit like little two-bit drug
smoking there's not like college girls
trying to sneak [ __ ] into [ __ ]
thailand yeah [ __ ] like that and then
they get caught yeah
so yeah okay so this episode is called
dark wrath i had actually forgotten
which one this was until we started
watching i was like oh this is the one
with the potential axe murderer guy okay
i remember this it's a good episode yeah
so the woman at the center of this and
this is her real name uh is cindy cerro
i think it's sarah s-a-r-r-o was hi
sarah orsaro i'm not really sure i think
they said sarah on the show um because
like i said some of the episodes that we
watched like one of the ones that i was
thinking about doing uh the guy was in
shadow and he was like using a pseudonym
because he didn't want to like his
identity to be known but i feel like
most of the people
you know that's their real identity so
when i looked at this woman yeah that
was her real identity
now at the beginning of the show when
they do the little
uh
recap or whatever
uh it says that cindy had a boyfriend
named jake um and that he had surprised
her and their two daughters with a new
house
um you know which is all fantastic and
everything
but you know they pay all this money but
then like all this crazy like
supernatural [ __ ] starts happening in
there and then
it's implied that like the house or
whatever is in the house like starts to
possess jake and makes him like
kind of like murderous a little bit yeah
when they saw the house the the girls
didn't really like it it was not a big
piece of property though yeah and it was
it was close to her mom's house so yeah
kind of local for them
but uh the move the the the the house
that they showed in the series it's
actually a pretty decent looking country
house
i don't know what it really looked like
but evidently she didn't like it
i imagine that like on this show i think
they usually
it's yeah what the the [ __ ] the houses
they put on the show are usually like a
lot nicer than the actual houses yeah
like some probably not always [ __ ]
dumb
i mean it wasn't livable yeah and the
thing about like when we did the show
but i think we talked about this when we
talked about summer win but i was like
when you look at actual pictures of
summer when like what it looked like
when they would have bought it yeah i
was just kind of like what like you
wouldn't be able to live in it even like
without millions of dollars of
renovations
yeah it was just like falling apart yeah
like whereas in the moo in the episode
it's like it looked kind of in rough
shape but decent like you could still
live in it like when it was fixed up but
that the real house absolutely did not
look like that it looked like a complete
you could find pictures of it online
yeah it just looked like it was falling
apart yeah
okay so i will note that like i said the
woman at the center of this who tells
most of the story i think one of her
kids is on there too like uh older
and uh cindy cerro actually wrote a book
that i found and it's called the wall
a horrifying true tale not pink floyd
the wall but um a horrifying true tale
of a haunting she read it in 2005 about
this experience now i read the first few
pages of it because that's all it's
available like on um because she doesn't
have like an e-book or anything like
that it's just like a paperback and on
amazon you can read the first few pages
and i read like some of the reviews
pretty much all of the reviews were like
oh my god the grammar and spelling and
everything is atrocious in this uh which
it is i've read worse but um but it's
still like not great yeah jenny's an
author okay and she's she's a grammar
nazi i am her yeah that's one thing
she's known for damn that [ __ ] [ __ ]
written well
yeah i mean and that's the thing and i
i'm just kind of like man uh this was
just like it seemed like
well the way she wrote it it wasn't
awful it was just the way she wrote it
was like kind of like stream of
consciousness like she didn't really
have like any like editing or any kind
of like
thing about like sentence structure or
anything like everything was just kind
of run-on sentences so it's the kind of
situation where she's trying to get the
story out there just trying to get the
product out there yeah she probably just
dictated it and it's yeah and i think
it's pretty short i think people
complain because they're like oh this
book was so expensive and it was only 99
pages or something like that um and i
think like a couple of people
said that they thought that
and i don't i'm sure this isn't true but
a couple who said well it reads like the
woman has like some mental problems or
like or that or that the people um or
that her or her uh boyfriend like were
not very sympathetic you know what i
mean like the [ __ ] that they did
um now the book is called the wall
because i was like i want to read it
well
because now it's like sounds like
somebody's personal memoir of some weird
[ __ ] that happened to him it's just
written the way it's written yeah which
that's probably what happened just tell
she's just telling you the story yeah
which uh that's kind of like looking at
the crime scene photos or something yeah
looking at testimony which like i said
that's fine it's fair enough yeah and
and honestly i think the best review was
three stars and they said and they said
well it's like a cool story but like
again the grammar is terrible and like
you can't really enjoy it because it's
like because it's poorly written but you
know creepy though
yeah well that's the thing um i don't
know if like i don't think i would pay
because i think it's kind of expensive
like i said all they all it has is like
a paperback it doesn't have like uh like
an e-book or anything because sometimes
99 pages a few bucks
it's not though it's expensive i think
like somebody said they paid like 20
bucks for it or something like that
which like yeah that's crazy but like i
said you know some authors will let you
read their books like a lot of authors
and i think mine are on there too like
if you want to read the ebook like if
you have kindle unlimited you can read
it for free uh which is nice and like a
lot of said like ebooks are usually only
two or three bucks like depending on how
long they are but yeah so i was like so
why is this book called the wall because
i didn't see anything like having to do
with the wall like in the episode
apparently what it is from what i could
glean of reviews and like just reading a
couple pages of it is that there was
something about like one section or like
one spot on one particular wall in the
house that she kept like fixating on
that everybody was like fixating on and
she came to like associate it with
that's like the entrance to hell or
that's where everything is coming out
yeah so they didn't mention that in the
episode so i just thought i would
mention that so like i said i want to
kind of go into the episode and then at
the end i'll say
you know how it differed from apparently
what happened in real life okay
so this episode takes place it starts
out in
1991. um and it's this place called
belleville illinois which is right
outside of st louis like i said i've
never been to illinois so i don't really
know like at that so cindy at this point
is 34 years old and has kind of lived in
this little town for a couple of years
now right around the time that they were
thinking about moving um she starts
having like recurring nightmares right
and in this recurring nightmare uh she's
kind of like walking down these stairs
in a house that's not the house that she
lives in uh at the time and she's like
um she's like i just kept feeling like
something was after me or was trying to
kill me and i was like kept having this
dream where i was on these stairs in
this house that i didn't recognize and
that there was something like after me
so at this point like cindy i guess she
was like a stay-at-home mom she had a
couple kids uh at the time one of them
was seven
in the show they called her christy and
then uh
there was a nine-year-old and in the
show they called her brooke now these
might be pseudonyms like for the show
because in her book she says the girls
names are sydney who's the nine-year-old
and lindsay who's the seven-year-old so
i don't know i'm assuming she used her
kids real names in the book and maybe
they just changed them for the show
because they were minors but yeah so
that's what i'm i'm just gonna use the
show names because i think that's what i
wrote down
so cindy has this long term boyfriend
named jake who's played by like that
bald kind of sketchy looking dude in the
episode who kind of looks like i mean
yeah he kind of seems like a jerk from
the beginning he's kind of like a kind
of like a a leaner
pretty muscular uh michael ironside for
some reason he was reminding me of
michael irons oh yeah i could see that
yeah like his face is a little bit like
narrower and sharper yeah but he kind of
like but he kind of yeah he did have
some michael ironside yeah yeah
i actually like the actor i like the
actor i think he you know he he makes a
good villain
yeah i think make a good villain yeah he
does yeah he's probably been in some
other haunting episodes yeah yeah he's
in a couple other ones i i just don't
remember which one i don't either like i
said because we've seen so many of them
and like sometimes they overlap yeah
zach said oh damn you're doing a
haunting again yeah i told you i'm
friends online with an actor from the
show like which one
because we were just talking like before
you got here talked about how they have
like a stable of actors that keep like
turning up over and over again it's
always amusing to be like hey it's that
guy yeah i like him yeah yeah it's like
that's pretty cool where's that raccoon
that goes to the cover that guy was in a
couple of them yeah yeah
but yeah there he goes yep thank you
thank you
oh somebody did yeah you're a couple
well i'm a little bit behind because i'm
like on a delay
thank you trey
yes i was hoping you all do a haunting
episodes again thanks guys yeah okay at
least once a week yeah we're gonna start
doing them let's just do them on mondays
that's like easier for me to keep track
of so we'll just do like a haunting
mondays i might even do like a little
like i said like a little intro to go
after the matinee intro so it's like woo
it's haunting monday yeah we're gonna
try to you know spice up our uh our our
[ __ ] uh game yeah there we go
and like i said give you guys what you
want so many people have like requested
yeah we get back to doing these again
yeah these and paranormal stuff so you
know yeah we're gonna kill two birds
with one stone yeah there we go
so yeah so cindy has his boyfriend jake
now jake uh works like overnight they
always do like on these episodes no it's
like everybody has night jobs i guess
it's so like the women and children can
be at home in the house like by
themselves yeah but it always seems like
the guy is always gone or it's like he
has a night job or something like that
i'm like wow i guess a lot of people
work graveyard shifts in this universe
but yeah so he works a graveyard shift
at a chemical plant in st louis now um
i guess like both of them both cindy and
her boyfriend they both grew up in this
town called caseyville
which is like a nearby rural town like i
said i've never been to illinois so i
don't really know um but they've
actually been talking about moving back
to their hometown um and sort of like
bringing up their kids there i think i
don't think they mentioned this on the
show but from
what i could
figure out from like what i read in her
book
i think only maybe one of the kids was
jake's
maybe and maybe one of them wasn't but
i'm i apologize if that's not right but
i thought that she implied that she had
met jake when she already had when one
of the kids was small all right so i
don't know if that's true or not but
that's kind of the impression that i got
so they're talking about bringing up the
girls like you know somewhere in their
hometown
so
jake
apparently surprises the family by
buying them a house there which is
closer to his work and also closer to
cindy's mom uh because cindy's mom was
sick she had some unspecified
degenerative degenerative disease now i
will say like right here from the outset
um that even though the show
said that jake bought them the house
like as a surprise that is not what
happened
uh cindy actually bought the house
she had um she was in some kind of
accident and had like a really bad back
injury and she got like a large cash
settlement like for the back injury and
um she bought the house with that and
actually matter of fact jake didn't
really like live with them prior to that
he kind of lived with his parents and
they would kind of move in and out like
off and on but he moved in with them
after she bought this house so i don't
know why the show made it seem like he
bought it like without
asking her but she actually bought it as
far as i could determine so i'm not
really sure why they changed that but
whatever
um
so they said okay so the house was like
affordable but it needed a lot of work
so they had to come up with like some
money for that
um
so the first thing that happens pretty
much like after they move in
at least according to the show is that
cindy is in the kitchen and she's
unpacking the dishes and like putting
the dishes in the cabinet it's like in
the kitchen
and
one of the cabinet doors basically just
like pulls itself off the hinges and
like flies across the kitchen
and she's just kind of like huh well
that's like pretty freaky but
you know you wouldn't think that was
paranormal necessarily because you'd be
like oh it's just like the hinges are
broken or some [ __ ] like that but then
i'd have to see it yeah and i've had
things like that happen yeah you know
boom it pulled that [ __ ] and like i said
it's hard to say because in the episode
it's they're reenacting it so you don't
know what it really looked like in real
life it might have just fallen off you
know what i mean um it rather than like
on the thing it was just kind of like
whew like it kind of flew like yeah and
she was just kind of like okay what the
[ __ ] and then she's like not really
thinking about it but then like another
one does the same thing
at which point she calls jake she's like
dude what the she's like
what's going on with the cabinets and
he's just like oh you know the hinges
are just old uh you know i'll fix that
whatever
so then the next thing that happens
cindy's like helping her daughters they
said the house only had two bedrooms so
both the little girls had to sleep in
the same room so she's like helping them
set up their room but then the lights
start flickering weirdly and like
buzzing and stuff
and uh she said she didn't really like
the bedroom she said it was like felt
really creepy in there and that was kind
of when she first
started feeling like something was wrong
with the house uh the girls also think
the room is creepy and for a long time
they're like we are absolutely not
sleeping in there because it's like too
spooky and they want to sleep in the
same room with the parents but you know
obviously they convince them not to and
the girls like grudgingly are kind of
like okay
now later that night and this and this
is kind of interesting to me because
remember how i said that cindy was the
one that actually bought the house and
presumably she went and like looked at
it and everything like that because she
said she'd been out looking at houses
um
but she says that after she moved in at
least according to the show
that she didn't realize until after
she'd moved in that this house was the
house that she had been seeing in her
recurring nightmares prior to seeing the
house prior to moving there remember how
i said like the nightmare started when
she had decided to move and when she
started looking at houses
and then she started having this
recurring dream about the specific house
which she didn't think she'd ever seen
before but then when she moved into this
house um the first night she was like oh
[ __ ] this is the house that's in my
nightmares so that's not good
you know what i mean
um
so she basically says
that started to freak her out and then
she said that she couldn't really like
sleep anymore all that well because she
kept waking up every hour feeling like
somebody was
watching her even though she couldn't
see anybody so it was like a really
oppressive feeling of like being watched
which like i said is usually something
that is uh happens like early on in
these kind of situations
um now the girls at this point they
really don't like sleeping in the room
either so they keep coming in and
sleeping in her room because like i said
she's sleeping in the room by herself
because her husband or her boyfriend
works at night so the girls keep coming
in there and like hey we want to sleep
in your bed and the bed isn't big enough
for like three of them so she's
basically like fine like let the girl
sleep in her bed and then she goes and
sleeps on the couch
and she said that she kept hearing like
creaking like somebody was walking
around and she said it just always felt
like somebody was in the house when
there wasn't supposed to be anybody in
there and that sometimes it sounded like
somebody was walking around even though
nobody was walking around and she said
she started this really started to freak
her out because like i said jake worked
at night and so they were at home like
all night by themselves
details on this like how long the the
the noises lasted for not really it
seems like a few like it was like a few
weeks like after they moved in and like
she just kept saying that
she
felt like somebody was in the house and
that like every now and then she it what
sounded like somebody like walking
around like the floor creaking and then
she'd go and there wouldn't be anybody
there okay so we're assuming it would be
in another room
and it would sound like a few steps yeah
or like upstairs or something like that
where it's like and then she would go up
there and there we go it wasn't hours of
it somebody walking around
not that i could not that i could
determine i mean it didn't she didn't
really specify because like i said you
know sometimes like on some of these
episodes yeah they're afraid they i mean
they try to like kind of compress
everything and sometimes they'll be like
a few weeks past or blah blah but a lot
of times it's hard to get a handle on
like the time frame i guess so that was
the thing
yeah and you know
really [ __ ] you know having seen this
kind of stuff myself
you have to be there
to know for sure you know what i mean um
having somebody just
give you a basic description yeah i
heard somebody walking around so i
looked yeah but what does that sound
like what is it how long you know you're
hearing somebody walking around what are
we talking about you sat there for five
minutes listening to somebody walk
around for five minutes or you thought
you heard somebody take a couple steps
you immediately went up there you know i
mean and these these programs don't
really
give you an accurate view of how it
actually went down
yeah it's kind of like light on
specifics real light on specifics like
uh in some of these cases i'd like to
have been there and witnessed it myself
to see exactly what it was they were
talking about
like the cabinet falling apart did it
just fall or was it pulled off
yeah did it like fly off yeah right yeah
how far did it how far away
did it hit the ground from the
because
i've seen both i've seen [ __ ] happen by
accident and then i've seen paranormal
stuff that's a big difference
big difference
it just sounds different it's a lot more
violent
danny rowling said the episode this is
interesting you bring this up it says
the episode where a single mother and
her son move into a haunted house with
evil spirit in the attic and the spirit
of a dead junkie that happened to be the
father of their neighbors was great that
was called the attic and we watched that
one last night we were actually going to
do that one tonight but uh today but
then we were like oh we'll do that one
later on because then we watched this
one i was like oh i kind of want to do
this yeah this one this one kind of took
priority to be a good pilot episode
because more happens in it it's not as
samey as as the attic the addicts
actually kind of say me if you looked at
the story arc
i did like that episode though and we
will absolutely get around to it because
like i said we did actually just watch
that one last night they were taking
pictures of the ghost
yeah that was i'll show you the pictures
of the ghost they showed re-enactments
yeah see paranormal witness
um for all its later flaws
actually would usually show you the real
[ __ ] like if somebody took a picture and
said hey look it looks like an orb or
whatever the [ __ ] um then they would
show you the actual picture not like a
cooler looking like reenactment of it
yeah so you know haunting could show you
a better picture yeah
a cloud with a smile in it [ __ ] that
kind of [ __ ] with eyes you know this is
what we have
yeah danny rowling said that was a sad
episode kind of it was actually
um zach said the episode that [ __ ] me
up most as a kid was one where the teen
girl was being tortured by the burn dude
in her closet the makeup they did on his
was on him was so upsetting i kind of
remember that one if we get around to it
i'll let you know because like what
season was that yeah what name was that
yeah maybe like narrow it down because
like i have to that sounds vaguely
familiar because i think we've seen
95 of the episodes i'm pretty sure i got
to see how long how many seasons this
this went on for yeah i think i have up
to season seven i think yeah and like i
said i'm pretty sure
most of the other seasons are available
like on stream like on pluto or
something like that like i think you can
watch them with commercials yeah i don't
think you can get dvds for them no i
think after season seven they stopped
doing stuff because because they're just
on streaming you can just watch them i'm
sure i mean
probably off the stream yeah they would
i mean i'm sure like i said pluto i
think has i don't know how many seasons
they have on there but i think they have
them on there so you can just like watch
them with commercials so okay so after
this point thank you mrs evans already
party thank you love that you guys are
doing these again hooray delicious i
said this was such a this was a good
idea yes wasn't it
[Laughter]
people people were jonesing for
paranormal yeah and they like the
hauntings and these are actually fun to
do they're actually good in each one of
these episodes from from especially the
the first few seasons of the haunting
were as good as a horror movie
yeah i mean it really has like good
production and the acting in it is good
and everything yeah i mean they were
better than the amityville horror
the original movie well yeah i would
definitely take some of the haunting
episodes over over some like cheaper
horror movies i've seen for sure you
know what i mean they just they know
what they're doing yeah as long as you
don't take them too seriously they're
just fun they're fun and they're kind of
like uh relaxing you know what's funny
is like you know how much you love the
the score like the music for it and
everything you can actually like buy the
soundtrack album like with the guy i
can't remember his name i meant to like
write it down but like the guy that does
all the incidental music there looks
evil like
[Laughter]
it's so cool but yeah okay so all this
stuff is going on with the creaking and
the presents and everything like that so
one night cindy's talking to her mom
anita on the phone now her mom lives in
an apartment
uh
the show said across town but in real
life it was like seriously like a
five-minute walk like you could walk to
her house you know what i mean from
their house
so uh so she calls and when she's on the
phone with her mom the tv comes on by
itself like kind of all staticky and
cindy's like what the [ __ ] and so like
she turns it off but then it pops back
on again uh which is something that we
had happen in our old at our old house a
lot a whole period of that that went on
for months it would happen like every
day or every other day like for several
months like that [ __ ] tv would come
on
and one time it came on in the room we
were sleeping yeah but not usually it
was usually in the living room usually
living room and then when the cable
people came i complained about it they
looked at me like
that shouldn't happen
i was like okay i was like but indeed it
does happen they're like do you have a
cat walking across a remote or something
i was like no
and he said well what do you think it is
and i said ghost
you're like no i'm serious i think it
might be yeah zach says by the way the
actor on the show i'm friends with is
johnny alonso he has one of his episodes
on his youtube channel and i talk to him
on instagram always has a spiky kind of
emo hairstyle can't miss him all right
tell him we're big fans yeah i'm gonna
have to like look him up now i'll look
on his youtube channel
so yeah so
so the tv's popping and stuff like that
and she's just kind of like okay so
mom's like well
is something wrong and she's like no no
uh everything's fine gotta go bye uh so
the next morning i guess after this
phone call like the tv coming on and off
cindy's out in the front yard gardening
like you know planting some flowers or
whatever and she says that some
invisible what's this like came up and
pushed her so hard that she like goes
down like for sort of like face first
into the dirt and this like freaks her
the [ __ ] out i guess as it would like if
you saw some invisible thing like
pushing you well you wouldn't see it
would you you would just feel it um she
doesn't really want to tell jake about
this uh because she knows how he'll
react uh so she does sell him and he
gets really angry he's like look we just
moved in here nothing's wrong nothing's
going on we can't afford to move so just
like quit your whining pretty much
um
now the girls and like i said this is
not
the impression that i got like from
reading the book and some of the reviews
of it
but
on the show it says the girl said oh the
parents had always got along fine before
they moved here but now they fought all
the time i don't think that's exactly
the case they didn't talk to both
daughters i think they just talked to
the older one like and she was grown
like obviously
so um
i guess like some more weeks went by
there's more like weird activity like
the nightmares uh you know feelings
being watched thank you mark
i know i guess like i said this was a
good idea what is that is that a little
cat it's a little or a it's a little fox
it's a little kitty or a little little
fox thank you it says good job
you guys are gonna like it we're gonna
do at least once a week yeah
i mean you know
samantha says first season was good what
pissed me off is they wouldn't tell
where the houses were and they never
took you to the real places
well then i noticed they would reuse
some houses in more than one episode
yeah and some of them like i said you
couldn't really tell because sometimes
people would use their real names like
in this uh episode but they never used
the real house i guess they didn't want
people to go you can find out if you
know what you're doing like
um
haunting in florida
not only did i find that house i went
and looked at it i didn't go
bother those people but i did look at it
and i didn't get any [ __ ] strange
feelings about it
six months later i went into a damn
hardware store and a guy helping me i'm
looking at him like this [ __ ]
familiar and then it was ed dunham i
said you had done him yeah
like right around the corner from our
old house like right over there
then we became friends i'm still friends
with ed dunham he's on my facebook page
he's
old army ranger guy became a damn
justice of the peace and he'll uh marry
you now
he'll dress up as an army ranger and
marry he'll dress up in a kilt and marry
you but uh he told me more about the
house uh and what happened there it
wasn't all there in the in the story
it never is like i said i kind of want
to get into that with this too because
there was a lot they left out yeah and
he didn't
he didn't mention much in the story
about what what the kids said and did
and what they saw the kids were more
involved in it and he was trying to keep
them out of it kind of
you know
didn't want to you know didn't want to
blow the kid's cover you know whatever
well i think that's kind of the case
with this one even though her grown
daughter like one of her grown daughters
on this show was on there but for
whatever reason they changed the kids
names they didn't change her name
because she's an adult but the kids
since they were young i guess they
changed the kids names because they the
names they called them were not the
names that she called them in her book
and ed and his wife broke up
a little while about a year or two after
that after that episode was filmed
so
the the entire dynamic of the family
changed he said that the damn
that haunting in there
he said it had something to do with the
end with with their relationship getting
[ __ ] up
said it was just put a lot of stress
under the whole [ __ ] face well it
would wouldn't it i mean you know it
makes total sense well i would stood
outside of it and looked at it see if i
could pick anything up from that house i
knew where it was and i confirmed him i
gave him the address because yeah that's
it
and it felt normal
but then again i'd have to go in there i
didn't spend time in it
i wake that [ __ ] up though
yeah like sometimes if it's based on
like if the people are using their real
names and they use the real city where
it took place a lot of times you can
find it and i think like i said in this
case you could probably find it because
you know the woman wrote a book about it
yeah and in the case of haunting in
florida that's deltona and where we were
living at the time it was [ __ ] 15
minutes away so i just rode up there on
a bike yeah
yeah deltona and deltona is not far yeah
i didn't want to bother the people there
well yeah because but i was just going
trying to see if i could get the vibe
off of it if it looked different than it
did on google earth and it looked the
same pretty much but it nothing like
okay here's the thing
the house that they used
in the episode is on that block
but that's not the house
they used oh interesting so they used a
house that was on the same street but
they didn't use the actual yeah they
used a nice one that was on the corner
interesting all right the one that he
was in was nowhere near that nice well i
guess maybe
they're just kind of like maybe they ask
everybody on the street it's like hey
can we film in your house for however
long it takes and we'll give you x
amount of dollars right and
okay yeah so at least they do try to get
something in the same area it was it was
in this on that same block
okay but they they filmed it if i
remember correctly they filmed it in a
way where you could not see
the uh the address written on that on
the house yeah so you couldn't
if you didn't know that street you would
never be able to find that house right
you know well yeah they probably have to
sign an agreement like with the people
that let them film there it's like hey
we're gonna like cover up the address or
change the address so you don't have
like a bunch of [ __ ] right lunatics
like camping
the house that they show was only like
uh three houses over
okay yeah
that's just that's really interesting
yeah
i'm just gonna i'm now i'm kind of
curious as to like all the backstory
about all this kind of stuff like with
how they've come about like finding
house and filming so yeah okay so weeks
are going by uh they still have the
nightmares they're still having feelings
like people are watching them they have
like all the kind of weird electrical
anomalies like tvs going on and off
lights going on and off that kind of
[ __ ] um some of the taps start running
with like black water very ambitious
horror um although they made it kind of
look more like blood
in the show even though they said oh the
water's black or whatever um now cindy
says she wasn't a religious person to
start out with but you know i guess to
cover all her bases she goes and like
buys some pictures of jesus and [ __ ] and
like puts it uh puts all of that stuff
around which if you're if you watch a
haunting with any regularity you know
that that just makes the ghost mad so i
don't know why
why everybody like insists on putting
crosses and virgin marys and [ __ ] like
that over your house because then the
ghosts are just gonna get pissed off and
like start throwing [ __ ] around like uh
so yeah so not long after this
uh something really weird happens she's
downstairs and jake is supposedly
sleeping upstairs he sleeps during the
day because he works at night and she
said that she heard him calling her
like hey cindy come up here or something
like that but when she goes up there to
see what he wants he's fast asleep like
in the bed and while she's out there in
the hallway
um
like a pillow suddenly kind of comes out
of nowhere and is like pressed over her
face and is like suffocating her
um so she like kind of fights it off
she's like screaming and stuff jay comes
out to see what's wrong but of course
doesn't believe her she's like hey this
[ __ ] pillow just came out of nowhere
it's like trying to [ __ ] kill me um
and again like starts getting really
angry that she wants to move she's like
look i can't stay here um and he's like
well you know we don't have the money we
just moved here you just need to like
suck it up and deal with it we're not
leaving period
so at this point cindy's like okay well
uh i can't really live with this so she
just starts calling around to a bunch of
churches and nobody would help them
until they finally found this one guy
gives you a catholic priest named father
thomas
and so she goes and sees him and he
seems like he's gonna help uh he tells
her the problem's probably demonic you
know because that's what they're gonna
do um he wasn't a warren but that's kind
of the same kind of [ __ ] they'll always
say he says okay well i'll come and
bless the house in a couple of days um
but you know i have to do the preparing
for you after fasting and praying and
all that [ __ ] that you have to do like
before you come bless the house because
you can't just bless it i guess uh so he
gives her he's like well in the meantime
here's a bible um if you ever like feel
like something's like freaking you out
or something like that read psalm 91
which i can't remember how that goes um
and that'll protect you until i can get
there to like do the blessing now at
this point this is where like the
[ __ ] rubber really hits the road
because that night like after apparently
like after she went to see the priest
um she's waiting for jake to come home
and when he does come home he's
not right like basically on the show
they show him just like coming out of
the car and like he looks like all
[ __ ] spaced out and they do kind of
like a red flashy eye thing i don't know
if that really happened or not
and he basically just starts busting
down the front door with an axe like i
said like jack torrance style
so she's flipping the [ __ ] out screaming
uh she calls the cops and she says
thankfully the cops got there before he
was able to like get all the way in like
with the axe and like kill her because
that looks like what he was gonna do so
the cops come and take him away and at
this point this is not clear but they
actually said on the show at this point
cindy realized that it was actually
probably jake who had done the [ __ ] with
the pillow like maybe he had snuck up on
her somehow i don't really know how that
happened
but because the way they made it look
like in the show was that she
heard him calling but then she goes
upstairs looks in the bedroom and he's
laying asleep in the bed and then all of
a sudden pillow in the face and i'm like
well if he was laying right there in the
bed how how could he have done it i'm
not really sure i said that i have to
have to i'd have to hear her tell me
exactly yeah what it was
because this the haunting as good as the
series is it takes liberties
yeah it does you know
they're trying to tell you a good story
yeah
that's that's all it is
so
so yeah um
[Music]
so the cops come and arrest him
and you know like i said she's like
really glad the cops got there so quick
because it looked like he was just gonna
like chop her up so you know
uh at this point she's like okay i don't
want to stay in this [ __ ] house so
her and the girls
uh while he's in jail presumably they go
to the mom's house or the mom's
apartment um because she's like well if
that can do that to jake then it can
maybe hurt the kids and i don't want
that to happen so they go and stay with
like the mom
now while she's staying with the mom she
has another
dream sort of nightmare
and in this dream she sees like a group
of people in like black robes and hoods
and [ __ ] standing around an open grave
with a coffin at the bottom and chanting
some right or whatever she tells the
priest about this father thomas and he
says oh maybe there was some group that
was performing some necromancy demon
summoning mumbo jumbo deal on the land
where your house was uh cindy is kind of
like relieved sort of like to have this
dream because she's like oh maybe this
explains like part of what's go what is
going on there like maybe this group was
there and they summoned a demon like
through going through a dead body or
some [ __ ] like that i don't know they
were just like pulling out their ass
probably
um so father thomas shows up to do the
blessing
and he's like well i want you like i
want cindy and the girls to be there for
it even though they're kind of like uh
yeah we don't really want to come back
to the house because they haven't been
staying there they've been standing with
the mom um you know since the whole acts
incident
so but they do they come there he does
the thing and then cindy and the girls
move back in now the night that they
moved back in at least as what the show
showed
uh cindy said she immediately like felt
the presence again like the hairs rose
on the back of her neck and then she
felt something invisible like grabbing
her
then as the older daughter is like
walking down the stairs
something picks the daughter up several
feet at least according to the show and
pushes her against the wall like that
like and she's like stuck there
on the wall
uh obviously they're all like freaking
out and screaming everything thing this
is absolutely the final straw
so they get the hell out that night
uh now the show says sending the girls
stayed with cindy's mom while she tries
to try to sell the house
now
apparently even though
this is crazy
so cindy and jake obviously didn't uh
make up after that i mean that's kind of
hard to come back from like you know
your boyfriend almost killing you max i
don't think there'd be any forgiveness
going on there but uh but yeah so uh
they so they break up now cindy starts
working at a hotel nearby and eventually
is able to save enough money to purchase
a new home uh jake she actually doesn't
press charges against him because her
feeling was that well he was possessed
by the demon thing that was in the house
so it wasn't really him and i'm just
kind of like i don't think i would take
that chance you know what i'm saying i
don't think i would but okay that's you
know i'm not judging but yeah she was
like so she didn't press charges so i
guess he
didn't serve any time okay and drop
charges i guess yeah and so like later
on he was even allowed to see the girls
like on weekends i'm assuming it was
hoping it was supervised visits not
really sure
now at the end of the show it says the
house remained empty for quite a some
time until a couple from out of town
bought it and then with a few within a
few months reportedly uh the daughter of
this family started feeling like an evil
presence in the house and the family
subsequently moved out like they weren't
i didn't really find that much
information about that
now
from what so that's where the episode
ends
but from what i could glean from reviews
of the book
several things were actually left out of
the episode now this is just kind of the
things that stood out to me
um i think that one thing that they
didn't put an episode which i don't know
why they didn't was apparently cindy or
the kids or something
uh saw on at least one occasion and
possibly multiple occasions like some
like a man in the window like in one of
the windows when no one was supposed to
be in the house looking out or looking
in uh i don't know i don't know it
didn't say i'm guessing like looking out
like they just kept seeing like a shadow
of a man like something like that yeah
and i don't know
that's what i'm saying i don't know what
well there was one shot where they
showed like the house and there was like
a curtain and i was like are they trying
to show that there's like somebody in
the window but i couldn't see anybody in
the window so i don't know maybe they
were showing that and i just didn't see
it because it was too dark or whatever
could be that they edited it out by
accident or they just didn't have time
maybe i mean i don't know
um another thing too that they did not
mention was that the boyfriend jake was
uh an alcoholic
which uh again like the show didn't
really mention that um and he had been
like before they uh moved in yeah just
didn't want to call him an alcoholic
maybe not yeah i kind of yeah i kind of
feel like it's you kind of have to like
when you're talking about real people
and especially when it's real people who
don't want to be interviewed with the
show or somebody that you're not with
anymore yeah you kind of gotta like
watch your p's and q so you don't get
sued or something yeah that's why you
know when we uh
did mountain poltergeist
in the book but didn't mention that
wesley was autistic because he [ __ ]
hated being called autistic yeah he was
autistic though autistic and deaf yeah
but uh
i think we touched that up in later
editions though i think we put it back
in there didn't we i can't remember it's
been such a long time we might we might
[ __ ] put out new additions to that
book anyway
there was some stuff that uh red
reminded me of
oh no that was in there we put that in
there anyway yeah i mean that was a long
time ago yeah it was a long time ago red
was a better witness than i was because
he was older than i was yeah
he was an adult and you were yeah and
you were like 13. 13 14 14 i think yeah
so he remembered [ __ ] that i'd have
forgotten about he'd [ __ ]
he says remember when the matchbox cars
did this and then i was just like i
remember all my hair standing oh yeah i
had forgotten about the damn knife being
thrown i forgot all about that i blocked
that out
yeah we i mean we added that like i said
because yeah it was in there yeah that
was in there
but yeah so she didn't mention uh they
didn't mention that he was uh an
alcoholic um well another thing they
didn't mention was that cindy said that
she felt like she had left her body on
at least one occasion um while she was
in the house so i guess that was
something else that that experiences
yeah
um interestingly too the family actually
had a dog
uh and they didn't mention that on the
show usually they'll put the pet in
there and uh but the dog
they left it tied up outside like all
the time which you know why maybe you
want to talk about that and then yeah
that's what i'm saying and at one point
the boyfriend like neglects to give the
dog food or water for a while yeah and i
don't know like i think the dog was okay
but the fact that they left it tied
outside without like sometimes
forgetting to like feed it or give it
water i'm like maybe you want to include
that that's yeah i'm kind of thinking
that maybe that didn't reflect so well
on them yeah um also this is another
thing that probably doesn't reflect all
that well on them and that's probably
why they didn't put in the show
after she and the girls fled the house
and stayed with their mom
now cindy still owned the house because
like i said on the show they made it
seem like jake bought it
um you know as a surprise but actually
cindy bought it as for at least as far
as i could determine i don't know if
jake i'm sure maybe jake gave some money
or something like that but maybe not
like because like i said she had a big
settlement from an injury and she bought
the house with that so i'm guessing it
was just in her name
um so yeah i wonder why they did it the
other way around i know that's really
weird it's just i don't i don't i
couldn't really think of a reason maybe
uh
maybe a haunting maybe they didn't want
to make it look like they were a
non-traditional and unreliable witnesses
that's kind of what i was thinking that
they wanted to make a homeowner because
it really does seem like and i don't
know if it's this has to do with the
production company or something like
that but haunting does
have a lot have kind of like a little
bit it's subtle but there is like a
subtle veneer of
like you know very conservative like
family values i have a type of thing
feeling that it might have been owned by
a company that was christian that's kind
i get that impression
like less so in earlier episodes but
there's even little subtle touches like
that where i don't know why they
wouldn't just say that cindy bought the
house and then
with her money and they didn't want to
go they didn't want it to look like she
was an ambulance chaser and that the man
was a [ __ ]
was was a freeloader that's what that's
probably i kind of feel like that's
probably what it was trying to portray
them as being more traditional and i
mean he had a job he wasn't a freeloader
yeah women
and women buy houses all the time she
had the money but he hurt but he lived
but he lived with his parents yeah and
maybe they thought that made him look
like a loser yeah um and therefore you
couldn't you wouldn't be able to trust
the story or the testimony yeah they
weren't
upstanding citizens which i don't really
see anything wrong with
the reality it's just they're trying to
make them seem more more traditional
traditional more yeah it's probably i
kind of feel like that's probably why
that's really the only reason i could
think of why they would why they
wouldn't mention that she had bought the
house because as far as as from
everything that i read from her book
like she bought the house she like she
went and looked at houses and everything
like i said she had a settlement from
injury like an accident they didn't want
to make her look like an ambulance
chaser i guess yeah but well then
they'll think you just do things for
money
yeah yeah maybe that's what it was yeah
yeah so um so yeah so what i was getting
to was that
so her and the girls fled the house
jake's already [ __ ] off he got
arrested and then like he [ __ ] off and
lived with his parents again um but
while she was had the house up for sale
she still owned it like while she was
looking for another house
and apparently reportedly
she would give haunted house tours of
the house to locals yeah
so and then but then she would complain
like that every time she went in there
and gave a tour like something would
attack her
but i'm just like well then why are you
giving tours of the house like but she
apparently gave tours of the house like
uh after after they fled from it yeah um
which they wouldn't have mentioned that
no who would have liked that no but um
here's the thing that's funny that it's
funny that um
a haunting would want to make sure that
all the witnesses were just
normal upstanding people
yeah because if you've been through this
kind of stuff
yourself
it gives you the experience you need to
help you pick through cases
and to see the patterns
and go through fake cases
real cases or real cases that have been
contaminated which that's all out there
paranormal stuff generally happens in
families that are under a lot of stress
yeah
stress is causing rsp
or current spontaneous psychokinesis or
there's some kind of
extra dimensional being that's in the
damn another dimension that's either
dead
uh or has never lived
uh some something is attaching itself to
the emotions in that area and it's uh
kind of manifesting itself
some places are just bad in star wars
terminology that they're dark they're in
the
is that they're they're strong with the
dark side because of things that have
happened there
it's never usually never happens around
normal happy families they're not
providing the energy
it's it's families that are under a lot
of stress they're providing this for one
of a better word this dark side energy
that fuels these things
so it's always families with problems
you know undergoing divorce or
their undergoing financial
crisis
um
family breakups uh just turmoil inside
the family
so it's never a [ __ ] family that's
totally traditional and [ __ ] happy
and picket fenced
the energy isn't there
but i guess the show like they kind of
want i guess maybe
you know not so much like appealing to
conservative values i think there's a
little bit of that but maybe they think
it's scarier if it's just like a regular
happy family that are suddenly and
inexplicably like assaulted by demonic
forces or whatever they think it's more
credible right better
we'll believe it if it happens to just
normal people to just normal people yeah
not like weirdos yeah but that's who
it's going to happen to you well of
course
or people with problems but everybody
has a problem everybody has problems
it's just a good
example
don't take it from me
you've you can read uh
math mountain culture guys uh best
example i've found
that reading and i'm like yeah that's it
the case is slightly contaminated
because i don't believe all the
witnesses but it was uh this house is
haunted by guideline playfair the
enfield case the infield poltergeist
case in england
that family was extremely poor under a
lot of pressure
and two girls going through puberty and
[ __ ] just weird [ __ ] starts breaking
out there's like
one of them starts speaking in a voice
it's kind of like tourette's syndrome
that mostly says nonsense
but objects were definitely moving the
cops saw people from newspaper reporters
saw things flying to lego bricks flying
from corners there and the same thing
that i'll tell you you never really
the objects just kind of appear from
nowhere out of your blind sides and
stuff you know when there's nobody over
there to throw it but
you mostly see the object arrive and not
so much leave
you know just weird
it has something to do with quantum
physics
oracle said you know as a twist it would
be interesting to see one of these
episodes where it turns out it was not
something supernaturally hanky going on
that would give it a real is it or isn't
it five yeah and it might kind of like
you know retroactively give
credence to like the other episodes
because they're like hey we're willing
to like do a show where it wasn't really
ghosts yeah so there's that yeah um so
yeah so
yeah in other words a hoax yeah
or it doesn't it doesn't necessarily
have to be a hoax it could be like um
something that you thought was
supernatural that actually turned out
not to be like it was something you know
there are some of the some of the cases
are are a hoax one of them the south
shields poltergeist i read the book
sounded really good but then after a
while thinking about it going no that
was a hoax
because they said they claimed certain
things happened but they didn't take
pictures of it even though they had
cameras right there
that plastic tables melted slightly
yeah why didn't they take a picture of
that and he said it returned to normal
an hour later conveniently so that was
convenient why didn't you
so they had all their recording
equipment but they never showed any
evidence it was just testimony even
though they had all the stuff there to
record it
yeah so that's kind of like why and you
know and it's supposed to be nurses be
professional investigators and you kind
of say sometimes too it's like
um
you know just because you don't get a
picture or something doesn't mean that
it didn't happen
it's just maybe sometimes it doesn't
want to be photographed or something
like that or it happens so fast you
don't have time but when that happens
over and over again and especially if
like if it's a long-term case where you
just kind of oh my god this happened
that happened i'm like and you didn't
get a single
video of it especially nowadays now that
everybody has [ __ ] cell phones yeah
and you can videotape stuff like within
an instant i don't know like why there's
not more well okay most there should be
more [ __ ] that you saw
when we were when that remote jumped off
that table could you have videotaped
that no because no it just happened
instantly you have only got a videotape
of you going up look that thing on the
floor yeah that just hit the ground a
few seconds ago yeah because i wasn't
expecting it to do that and then like
after it did that it took me a second to
be like wait did i did that just do that
and it never did it again no it did dude
and then uh i'm standing in the kitchen
and the damn railing on the top [ __ ]
gets pulled off and the [ __ ] gets thrown
and it happened in an instant
boom it was all on the ground
so you would have only been able to
record the aftermath yeah go get the
camera look that hit the ground you
would have said now you put it there
yeah so you can never catch it in the
act in the case that i'm talking about
they said the table legs of the plastic
table melted
all right
they didn't get a picture of the melted
table
they said an hour later it went back to
normal well why didn't you you had a
whole house
this melted table
why didn't they put a camera on it to
like make sure like it did so in case it
did something well they would if you saw
a melted table and you got cameras
everywhere you're recording everything
that happened you would have taken a
picture of the table yeah
you had a whole hour to take a picture
of the table
they didn't it said it went back and
that was just one of the many things
that
the case was just too damn good they
they
they had read books about good
poltergeist cases and just rap just
wrote a book replicating
similar things yeah
but they had opportunities to get
evidence and they didn't collect any
so and that wasn't just me that said
that
steve mara
i mentioned that casey because yeah that
was an odd case when he says yeah i
don't believe it because neither do i
and it was because there was just too
many
too many too much good [ __ ] happened and
they didn't record it they didn't record
the aftermath
yeah that's and they had the equipment
very suspicious yeah
uh but yeah okay so
and i did
out of my case i got remember those old
polaroids that come out of the bottom of
the camera that was the highest
technology we had back then okay
and we took pictures of the [ __ ] laying
on the ground why the [ __ ] were we
running around taking pictures of towels
on the ground
didn't make any damn sense but that's
because that's we were just taking
pictures of the things that it was doing
you couldn't catch it in the act
but
i can show you pictures from the [ __ ]
early 80s of us taking pictures of
towels and patterns on the ground and on
on the bed and
things things upside down like the
rocking chair upside down
and it's because that's all we could do
and then we ran out of film back then
what was it with 15 pictures i think
eight pictures in the in the little i
don't know if it was eight or twelve or
eight or twelve in the cartridge and we
only had two of them the [ __ ] were
expensive back in the day
okay so all right so let me get back to
this because we're almost because we're
almost done i thought it was done no
okay see well that's what there it is
that's why i was just like trying to
like okay i'm like trying to finish it
up um but yeah so
like i said she actually gave tours uh
to people of the haunted house like
before she sold it also one thing one of
the reviewers pointed out about her book
that she wrote is like it seemed like
the kids were always like she was always
dumping them with neighbors or relatives
because they didn't want to stay in the
house um so they said something like oh
they were just like couch surfing pretty
much for the whole book um one thing too
that they didn't mention in the show was
that
i don't know i kind of feel like they
made it feel like seemed like this was
like a new like a paranormal experience
for cindy but in the book pretty much on
the first
first page or the second page she says
i've been a magnet for spirits ever
since i was a child or something like
that um so she was kind of like one of
those people's like oh i've always like
seen ghosts and stuff like that um yeah
so
also
she mentioned in the book and again they
kind of like finagled this a little bit
for the show uh her and jake were
already fighting all the time before
they moved into that house uh they would
break up and they would get back
together like i said they didn't even
really live together regularly um he
mostly lived with his parents
and uh so
i mean and they fought so much that so
much so that their friends and relatives
like joked about it like how they were
always fighting and like always breaking
up and getting back together again um so
there was that so it wasn't like oh we
moved to this house and then all of a
sudden like he turned into a douche and
we started like fighting and we didn't
fight before that is not the case they
fought and broke up all the time like
prior to that
now another thing i found this was from
another paranormal website this was
somebody that had read the book and they
liked the whole book and then they just
like mentioned some stuff that wasn't on
the show
um
one thing that cindy claimed that she
felt like not only she felt like she was
being like grabbed by invisible things
but also she felt like she's being stuck
with pins or burned with cigarettes uh
they also said the dog wouldn't come
into the house
um that she would like fill up a big
bucket of water
for the dog and like put it outside and
then like the next day it would be moved
across the yard and there'd be like big
footprints around it so that was in her
book then that wasn't on the show
they also didn't bring this up at all in
the show but apparently there was a
little boy who lived with a family in a
trailer like very near their house
and he started acting really weird
implication being that like the demonic
presence or whatever the hell that was
in this house was like affecting him too
this little boy actually
told jake the boyfriend that he was
going to quote unquote split jake's head
open with his tools and that he was
going to burn down his family's trailer
uh and that he would spit in uh cindy's
daughter's hair like so he was so i
don't know maybe the kid was just a brat
but i think like she was kind of writing
it like oh the
the influence of the house was like
affecting this neighbor kid or whatever
uh she also mentioned in the book that
she saw
uh apparitions that she saw a boy a man
an old woman
and something that looked like a pink
cloud of energy
and that she yeah and that she kind of
felt like um
the whatever the entity or entities were
were pulling were gaining strength by
pulling electricity from the house so
that was all in the book but they didn't
mention it on the show i don't think
they they didn't um show her seeing any
apparitions
on the but in the book apparently she
claimed that she saw several apparitions
so there's that
okay
i kind of think that uh something may
have happened
something may have happened at this
house might have been paranormal
i'm not going to discount it i wish i
was there to see it myself i'd be able
to tell you more but but certain key
elements to the story kind of ring true
now a person can read other good cases
and pull stuff out of those cases and
fake or something but
i don't know i got a feeling maybe
something happened here
the pink
energy cloud kind of reminds me of the
blue mist kind of mine was kind of like
an energy cloud's a good way of
describing it
although not really so you look at it
you're not really quite sure you're
seeing it you look directly at it and it
kind of
fades away you look as from you look at
it from the side and you can see it kind
of
whatever it is it's not
really there per se it's something
slightly in another dimension
it's weird
i know what you're talking about though
yeah but like i said they didn't like
show which like i said i don't know why
they didn't show if somebody saw some
apparitions or claim to see apparitions
you'd think they would put that on the
show because that was scarier but they
didn't like i said maybe in the earlier
maybe the reason the earlier episodes
are a little bit better is because they
were a little bit more restrained yeah
like maybe if you made some kind of wild
claims they'd be like yeah let's kind of
like back off on that a little bit just
so it seems like scarier because it's
more realistic i don't really know danny
goes face says he bought the first four
seasons of the haunting on on amazon for
25 bucks is great it was a great
purchase i got that same one that's that
yeah i think it's about that thick jenny
bought it for me has all the little tv
little cd cases in it it is a great that
those are the those the first four
seasons are the best
and that's for 25 bucks yeah that's a
[ __ ] steal
you could watch that [ __ ] all day long
you can put that gentle rotation never
get sick of them yeah we just watched
well well because there's so many it's
like and you kind of forget like some of
the details and stuff just put one in
and play go play all there's usually
three episodes on each disc
and you can kind of just zone out real
relaxed with that nice music and that
and that lovely narration
with that guy's voice
he really does in america there's real
evil
open doors i don't remember
you think we would have it memorized all
right
and then you come in and narrate some
[ __ ]
in the house an unknown evil
[Laughter]
bill and jed
you totally should have been on that
show that would have been so cool
yeah but that was like under the second
owner or third owner it wouldn't have
been as good
that's what i would like to have in that
[ __ ] like season two or three it had
been great yeah if you hadn't known
about it back then you could have been
yeah
all right so i guess we've man we've
gone on longer than the actual episode
yeah
than the actual episode of the show was
yeah
just having fun everybody's they're
they're in the comments section quoting
from the movies quoting from the series
it's classic man i know you all have
[ __ ] watched it watched this many
times zach says he'll just watch them
all that he's seen them all you know but
uh i think we have they're cult classics
now yeah they're called classics now
if you don't if you don't have them
go get them off amazon the first four
seasons 25 bucks delivered hell yeah and
it's on hard copy man
that way if the [ __ ] get an emp
attack or the [ __ ] end of the
apocalypse you'll be you could sit there
and just watch it
anyway watch it on a dvd player
yeah so this so this episode dark wrath
like i said that's from season four
and i'm pretty sure it's from 2007. i
think that's when that originally aired
so i don't know if anything they were
done well they were they were done real
well so yeah we'll definitely we're
we're definitely going to start doing
this every monday i decided yeah they
yeah i decided so everyone will be like
excited about that so tomorrow we'll go
back and we'll do the super chats and
everything we'll do out in there yep
so tomorrow we'll do another movie but
uh from now on
we'll we'll do a haunting episode on
monday ooh i think it's gonna storm
again it was a really bad storm like
earlier yeah and it sounds like it's
going to do it again uh and it's
probably like right about dinner time i
imagine he said 25 bucks used i got it
for brand new it's way more expensive
okay yeah okay so you can get 25 bucks
used yeah brand new is more and like i
said i think the other ones like five
six seven like i think i bought those
individually because yeah each only the
first four like came in yeah only the
first four are in the set after then
each each um
season is on one disc
and uh they're not quite as good they're
okay i mean you know but they're not as
good as the original four
just there's something about it's the
same narrators uh most of the actors no
i think the actors have changed a bit
but there's just something about him the
storytelling isn't quite as good
or it's just different i don't i don't
know it seemed they seemed more
they seemed more generic as they got
older for some reason
i kind of felt like they went a little
more outlandish and they also seemed to
go a little more churchy
yeah it seemed like the originally the
original episodes
they would kind of have
um they would show like because we it
was almost like a joke where you know
the priest would come and bless the
house and then everything like [ __ ]
would just go like way off the rails
like it's gonna get really bad yeah so
but i feel like the later shows they
didn't show that as much like usually
they would have like the priest come in
and ha like everything was fixed the
later shows were also more uh cg special
special effects driven yeah and i didn't
love that they almost looked kind of
like a [ __ ] like like a horror movie
from the era which i guess they thought
that was good but they took a lot of
liberties in the way that things are
described it was better to kind of leave
things open to the imagination yeah yeah
more documentary like i said more it's
more realistic like i said some of them
aren't that realistic but
i think it was like they were creepier
when they were more grounded in reality
when you have like a cgi like demon
popping out the wall it's just kind of
like that yeah and it's happening
[ __ ] a lot and it looks it looks very
hollywood you know it's just something
about it
i liked it better when it was the first
four seasons when they were a little
more simple yeah
they are better
yeah man i said i could
[Laughter]
too bad we've already done demonstration
yeah but yeah
that might be able to do it again
that was a long time ago we can do the
[ __ ] again that's true
all right so thank you everybody for
dropping by we're really glad how that
this uh idea has proven so popular so
we'll do another one on monday tomorrow
we'll go back to doing another uh movie
review and then wednesday we'll be doing
uh kind of a paranormal show on
wednesday too because we're talking
about the british premonitions bureau
from the 1960s so hopefully we see
everybody back here again tomorrow
evening have a good rest of your night
and we will see you guys again tomorrow